hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the ftx crypto cup we are in the
knockouts it's magnus carlsen versus
hikaru nakamura
and the nakamura really destroyed magnus
in round one so now magnus really needs
a win to bounce back and
uh well this game uh is uh what is i i
would say it is just as good as the
previous one but uh you
will be the judge of that as usual so
magnus has the white pieces here and he
needs the win to bounce back into the
match so here we have e4
uh e5 by hikaru knight to f3 knight to
c6 and
bishop to c4 we have bishop to c5 by
hikaru and
no we will not see it this time either
here magnus just castles uh we have
knight to f6
and now d3 so this has all been played
before a normal uh joko piano
at the italian game we have castles and
h3 now
black also plays h6 takes away the g5
square from
uh white's bishop we have c3 and now
d6 we have rook to e1 and now a5
preventing
any rapid expansion here would be for a5
a4 and b5
so here we have d4 uh striking in the
center and now
bishop to b6 we have bishop to e3 and
here
we have a trade in the center e capture
c captures and
now d5 uh we have e captures on d5
uh and now uh well you could uh you
could capture this but
this isn't all that impressive if you
capture this then you get something like
bishop captures queen captures
and after the queen is kicked away then
we can already grab some more space with
d5 and so on
so here we have knight to e7 uh
just getting the knight out of the way
we have knights to c3 and now comes
knight e captures on d5 magnus plays
queen to d2
and interestingly hikaru already had
this position last year against fabiano
caruana
also in an online game and he continued
with knight
captures on e3 but here after
considering the position
not for a very long time he played c6
and now
magnus has a very very uh
well brutal idea he plays
bishop captures on h6 and probably one
of the reasons why fabi eliminated this
bishop here
but now uh hikaru needs to make a move
and
he really started spending his time here
he spent over seven minutes on this move
uh in the end he decided to capture the
bishop and now
queen captures an h6 so what do you do
here uh knights to h7 is the only way to
successfully defend the position
yeah but if you don't know this it's a
very hard move to find hikaru played
queen
bishop to f5 uh sort of as to use this
bishop to g6 maneuver to help out with
the defense but
this doesn't really work so feel free to
pause the video here and already on move
16 win the game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding uh
either
uh knights the h4 or rook to e5 both of
those moves
you will play doesn't really matter in
what order so if you found any of those
moves really congratulations
uh as that wins the game and magnus
played
rook to e5 so now the bishop is under
attack hikaru shifts it over to g6 which
is why he played
f5 in the first place and now magnus
doesn't go knight to h4 knight h4
is a bit of a quicker weight in the game
magnus plays
rook to g5 which requests a bit more
grind
i will however show knights to h4
because it's super uh
interesting now we're just threatening
to capture this and you know
it's gonna be game over uh this knight
can't really move
ever from here because then the df pawn
is pinned we can even play queen
captures and g6 and ideas like that
so here what you would see is most
likely bishop characters on d4 attack
the rook now we're gonna capture here
and after captures
not eliminated this pawn but now we play
knight captures on d5 and now we're
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries
c captures on d5 and now rook to g5
going after this pawn
so you can't really go after the bishop
you have to play something like knight
to h7
to save your king and then after rook
captures on d5 it's again game over
because a lot of nasty discoveries are
now happening and
that's just it whatever you play let's
say just this deliver check we win the
queen
and this game over so a knight to the
age for a bit of a quicker win for
magnus here just in case if you ever
find yourself uh in this position if you
might
you know play it with white but okay
magnus played a rook to g5 and now comes
knight to h7 attacking his rook we have
rook to g4
uh you could also try rogue captures on
g6 right away but this doesn't work for
white because here after captures and
captures king h8 is just very strong for
black
and now uh the the king is no longer on
this diagonal so
it doesn't really matter and if you try
something like this bishop d3 now
threaten checkmate
queen c7 defends against checkmate now
you can even play king to g8 maybe just
double up here and you know enjoy uh
maybe even a better game so instead
after knight to
h7 we have rook to g4 magnus just gets
his rook out of harm's way and now
rook to e8 another very strong move by
hikaru
and now comes knight captures on d5
if you try knights the e5 to add another
attacker to this uh hikaru just captures
this or even rook to e6 is possible but
even capturing
and queen to f8 stops white's attack and
hikaru will look for his drawing chances
there
but here magnus plays knight captures on
d5 c captures and bishop to d3 this is
how he adds another attacker to the g6
square
we have knight to f8 now ahikar adds
another defender and not knight to e5
adding a fourth attacker to the bishop
here
and now you don't really have all that
uh many choices you could
capture this but this doesn't really do
all that much now
so here rook the e6 was played adding
another defender
but now bishop to f5 hikaru moves it and
only now
magnus captures here so knight captures
on g6 we have a nice capture fest here
we have f captures uh bishop captures
rook captures we have rook characters
knight captures and queen captures with
check and after all of these characters
uh hikaru is now up a bishop but magnus
only needs a few moves to
finish the game for example rook to e1
to e5 and then
any of the squares to made the blacking
and will hikaru have enough time to
activate his pieces
uh it is very unlikely so here king to
h8 was played
and nothing else is really all that
helpful magnus delivers a few checks
king queen h5 checking the g8 queen to
g4 check we have king to h7
and now and only now rook to e1 and now
it doesn't really matter what you play
uh point is if you play something like
queen g8 you offer a queen trade you
allow rook to e7 and this
infiltration already is enough to win
the game for example queen f4
check and now there's really nothing
queen g5 you you're going to deliver
this check
and now the king has to go here and now
for example this will be checkmate
so instead after rook d1 we have rooked
the c8 hikaru tries to get his
rook active at least somehow but now
rook the e6 by magnus and it was in this
position i know 31 that
hikaru nakamura resigned the game and
magnus bounces back in the match by
winning the second game and here you
resign
uh because after a few moves let's say
rook c1 checking h2 and bishop to c7
check
once g3 is played there are no good
moves here for for black
uh whatsoever you could try some like
rook c6 the counter district but now we
just go in for the kill queen g6
checking it
and now this just wins the queen uh with
tempo with
check and now after king g7 yes okay
black does have a
bishop in the rook uh but uh queen and
all of these past pawns is just uh
impossible to play this so after rook to
e60 carl resigns and
the match is now again a match so we'll
see what happens
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank caleb ewing
uh michael voska
reuben taverick dane scott and vlad
ularu for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of this very
nice event uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day